but I never shared this with anybody
okay but you you took it that's the
problem okay that's where we're at right
now this is Dr Shannon yo two hours
after she was arrested and when the FBI
picked her up they also found a
briefcase containing four thousand
dollars and suspect she was about to
flee the country
the then 56 year old might make for an
unlikely spy but nudged by an FBI
interrogator she's about to talk herself
into a 14-year prison sentence for
stealing 120 million dollars worth of
trade secrets in the process the case
will reveal details of how industrial
Espionage has become a Cornerstone of
China's economic growth
my name is Jordan Robertson and I'm a
cyber security reporter for Bloomberg
here in London
this story is about an incentive system
that the likes of which the world has
never seen before
Dr Shannon yo was a chemical engineer
for Coca-Cola she evaluated the Coatings
that went inside all of the cans that
Coca-Cola makes what these formulations
do is they actually protect the can from
the coke they prevent the chemicals in
soda from eroding the can that they're
in for the companies that make it like
BASF Dow Chemical and axo Nobel the
chemical formulas are a closely guarded
secret they cost an estimated 120
million dollars to develop so far no
Chinese company has managed to develop
an equivalent and yo has the formulas on
her hard drive
I have never shared any technology with
anybody in China
okay I go back to China because my mom
being in last stage of her life and so I
took every opportunities to go to China
to see my mom at the start of the
interrogation yo is adamant that she's
done nothing wrong but she's being a
little disingenuous because she has been
going back to China to interview for the
Thousand talents program
the Thousand talents program is a
Chinese national government program and
it's designed to incentivize uh you know
ethnic Chinese who have moved abroad to
work or study to return to China and to
start businesses there the critics of
the program say it's really a
multi-billion dollar scheme that
incentivizes them to steal foreign
technology and bring it home with them
and this is the guide that the FBI
alleges has been helping her application
Liu Zhang Chen he's the chief engineer
for we hide Jin Hong group
and that company wants to get into the
business of making bpani the chemical
lining for Coke cans we had Jin Hong did
not respond to requests from Bloomberg
news for comment
the interrogation is almost a master
class in how you unravel a scheme like
this because at almost every stage the
FBI catches her in a lie the plan was to
form a new company that's one Adventure
company yeah that's what that's what Mr
new thinking okay but it was never get
there
for her part yo insists that all she
ever did was to introduce the Chinese
firm to some other companies interested
in getting into the business in the
interrogation room this is where she
starts to come unstuck did you guys sign
a contract
full
for your work over there
I did okay but there's no work there's
no work yeah right there's no work
because of my work basically just
introduced I did not do anything
unfortunately for you the FBI had a copy
of the contract
in Hong's responsibilities include
investing the initial amount of six
million you want and providing the
location among other preparation work
which is expected to take one year
cardi B
the responsibilities include to be the
chief technical officer of the project
providing technical assistance
leading the party's research and
development team and communicating with
foreign manufacturers and developing new
overseas joint ventures this just called
kingdol Miss yo it's not just talking
look look at the facts
you you signed a contract yeah they said
they would pay you
the contract was to help build a lab
they said when the lab was built you
would have shareholders in that lab and
then weeks later you're making emails
inquiring about building a lab it's not
just paper then the FBI agents reveal
their hand they have their voicemails
and have read her text messages in quick
succession they outline how she knew
that joining the Thousand talents might
invite the FBI's attention Liu has
suggested that she keep her job at
Coca-Cola to quote continue to leverage
the latest Technologies at Coke her
sister had received payments from the
Chinese government on her behalf yo
didn't want any publicity around winning
the Thousand talents for fear of
alerting U.S authorities and the coup de
grass a voicemail left by her sister
Joe says unlike other TTP winners who
are losers overseas she is doing well in
the United States she is the one taking
the risk during the current unfriendly
period between U.S Chinese relations and
she won't give her technology away
easily until she sees money for real
this time Yo's response is far more
muted well
I did not do an issue what her messages
reveal about that defense is she was
trying to share it she wanted to get
paid first and ultimately she was
prosecuted not based on whether she
shared it with the Chinese government or
not or did she take it that was a
central question and her messages show
that the end game of this was to share
that information and launch this company
in China and get rich yes this is a tale
about stealing Coke's other secret
formula but it's also about how China is
incentivizing espionage far beyond the
Realms of Defense technology and
National Security and into the furthest
reaches of the economy
for more on how yo was caught read the
full story on businessweek.com and
follow Bloomberg quick take on your
favorite platforms
[Music]
thank you